what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to d block europe no
competition before i start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and also
consider purchasing one of my
sweatshirts they help support the
channel all money i make from the
sweatshirt is just reinvested into the
channel new equipment whatever
um
yeah but anyways i've never heard of
d-block europe and i've never heard of
this song but it was trending so i'm
reacting to it today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he said you can get it if you
act right
that means
if you're a female right you can
get railed basically if you act right
but honestly i see a lot of the females
these rappers hang around
a lot of them don't act right
and they still get nailed i'm just
saying
[Music]
she came already
[Music]
she want to see
[Music]
[Music]
he mentioned a lot of stuff i heard
double d's um i heard that he's loyal
which is great you love a loyal king
we love a loyal king
um
yeah that's all i got for now 100 racks
on my teeth my lady on fleek
100 raps on my teeth my lady on
600 brick on the truck and that's 200
found
[Music]
he said i put the purse in the kitchen
is there a hidden meeting to that or
just
does he just experiment with his style
i don't i got no hate for someone that's
just a guy that likes to wear a purse
they're convenient
like i i don't see why a man can't wear
a purse
[Music]
um
i enjoyed this music video to be honest
um i really liked the four wheelers in
it i felt like that was like a nice
touch
um i also let me switch the screen okay
i also
i thought it was nice that he was
talking about his lady and i really
liked the beat in the beginning like you
saw me i was shimmying
moving my shoulders so i'm gonna give it
a four out of five not a five because i
just felt like the beginning was so much
better than the rest of the
like song but let me know what you guys
think in the comments let me know what i
should react to next don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and i'll talk
to you guys next time